[Musique]
la mer mineure est la plus grande lagune
d'eau salée d'Europe
étendue sur 135 km². ce décor pourrait
être paradisiaque s'il n'était pas
massivement pollué
[Musique]
Victoria habite sur ses rivages depuis
50 ans aujourd'hui elle n'envisage même
plus de se baigner
était transparente propre il y avait des
hippocampes c'était une mer vivante
maintenant elle est morte
si cette plage est relativement
préservée Victoria nous emmène à un
endroit où la mer est particulièrement
contaminée
comme vous le voyez ici le sol est
rempli d'algues sentez l'odeur d'oeuf
pourri qui s'en dégage
les autorités n'ont absolument rien fait
contre ça la seule chose qu'ils ont fait
c'est détruire cet écosystème
à l'origine de cette prolifération la
pollution urbaine mais surtout les
rejets de l'agriculture intensive
lorsque les algues s'accumulent en trop
grande quantités elle bloquent les
rayons du soleil il devient impossible
pour les autres végétaux de produire de
l'oxygène
régulièrement ce phénomène tue des
milliers de poissons
en 2016 80% de la végétation sous-marine
était morte pour prévenir de nouvelles
catastrophes écologiques rosées et son
collègue surveille de près la mer
mineure
on a combien de visibilité
chaque semaine ces techniciens d'un
institut de recherche mesure les
caractéristiques de l'eau un point de la
lagune attire particulièrement leur
attention l'embouchure de l'alborde ici
c'est le point le plus éloigné de la
Méditerranée c'est un endroit très
sensible parce qu'il n'y a presque pas
de courant et l'eau ne circule pas en
plus c'est ici que se déverse toute
l'eau qui arrive de la ville et des
champs
en laboratoire
le constat est sans appel
là vous voyez c'est l'albouronne sur
cette courbe vous voyez la concentration
en nutriments elle devrait être de 1,8
mg par litre maximum mais là on est à
4,5 fois plus que la normale
jusqu'à 5 tonnes de nitrates pourrait
être déversées dans la zone chaque jour
que donne l'analyse des nitrates écoute
la concentration est très élevée si on
la compare à celle de nos témoins
selon les scientifiques ces nitrate
proviennent des 60 000 hectares de
culture qui entourent la mer mineure
dans la région 20% du pays B dépend du
secteur agroalimentaire
Vicente est agriculteur comme tant
d'autres il souffre de cette mauvaise
image
on nous considère comme des criminels
dans certaines zones de la côte il y a
même comment vous dire des graffitis qui
disent agriculteurs assassins
agriculteurs criminels
pour réduire l'impact de leur activité
les agriculteurs de la région ont
déboursé 100.000 euros dans un vaste
projet de recherche
objectif capter l'eau salée des nappes
souterraines polluées pour la
dénitrifier la saumure un liquide
hypersalent dans lequel sont retenus les
nitres et séparés de l'eau douce elle
est ensuite déversée dans cette cuve
bonjour Vicente comment tu vas regarde
on utilise des copeaux issus de bois de
citronniers ou d'agrumes
il libère du carbone dont se nourrissent
tout un tas de micro-organismes qui vont
ensuite éliminer les nitrates présents
dans la saumure
en fonction des températures on peut
éliminer entre 75 et 90 % des nitrates
à grande échelle ce procédé produirait
de grands volumes de Saumur et personne
ne sait pour leur ou la rejeter sans
dommage pour l'environnement
[Musique]
en attendant la mer mineure vient de
devenir le premier écosystème en Europe
doté d'une personnalité juridique à
l'université de mourcy Theresa Vicente
s'est battue pour faire reconnaître les
droits à la protection à la conservation
et à la restauration de la lagune
ce nouveau statut est assuré par la
norme juridique la plus élevée qu'il
soit puisqu'il s'agit d'une loi ce qui
est inédit c'est qu'elle donne des
prérogatives à l'écosystème de la mère
mineure comme le droit en donne aux
individus ou aux entreprises
à présent les possibilités d'action en
justice seront facilitées et élargies à
toute personne qui souhaite défendre la
mer mineure autre nouveauté un conseil
composé d'environnementalistes de
politique mais aussi d'agriculteurs
devra veiller au respect de ses droits à
la cadane
les grandes corporations agricoles sont
incluses dans cette loi parce qu'il faut
qu'elle soit entendue mais il faut aussi
qu'elle comprenne qu'elles ne peuvent
pas faire ce qu'elles veulent la mer
mineure a des droits et il va falloir
les respecter
cette nouvelle loi redonne l'espoir de
pouvoir sauver un jour la mer mineure on
estime qu'il faudrait au minimum 20 ans
pour que cet écosystème se régénère